deflación que es la inflación a la
deflación es literalmente la bajada de
los precios o una disminución del nivel
de los precios por bienes y servicios
otra manera de pensarlo sería como como
la deflación es una disminución en el
nivel de los precios lo podemos ver como
la inflación negativa ahora imagina que
somos los chicos en la oficina de
estadísticas del trabajo y estamos
intentando calcular el index cpi y en el
primer periodo llamemos a este nuestro
primer período tenemos nuestro index cpi
para clientes urbanos el cual es el
citado con más frecuencia y tendríamos
esta canasta de bienes y en este estará
lo que son viviendas también transportes
combustibles y por supuesto hay que
dejar un espacio para entretenimiento no
podemos olvidar eso ahora en esta
canasta de bienes digamos en el período
1 indica ejecuta el consumo urbano
promedio de 100 dólares
luego vamos al segundo periodo y vemos
que es la misma canasta de bienes quizás
estamos haciendo algunos ajustes porque
alguno que otro producto se volvió
obsoleto y debemos reemplazarlo pero
dado todo esto asumiendo que todo está
igual todo además está igual
esa misma canasta de bienes está ahora
en 98 dólares por lo tanto el costo
total de bienes y servicios para esta
clase de consumidor promedio ha bajado 2
dólares o podríamos decir que estamos
experimentando inflación negativa de 2%
lo cual es otra manera de decir que
estamos experimentando deflación
ahora deflación no es la norma
especialmente para economías crecientes
la manera en la que nuestro sistema
económico actual funciona no es así
aunque si llega a suceder por ejemplo
japón en particular es el caso más
reciente el caso más famoso de la
extracción y la principal razón por la
que los economistas no les gusta la
deflación
en particular ver por qué a los
banqueros centrales en verdad les
desagrada la deflación es porque hace
más difícil llevar el control de la
economía es más difícil alimentar la
economía que a las tasas de interés
solamente o de hecho solo con imprimir
dinero una cosa que si quiero dejar
clara es que aunque la deflación no es
algo que normalmente vemos si sucede y
con frecuencia por ejemplo en el sector
de la tecnología compras una laptop la
compras hoy por mil dólares y seis meses
después la encuentras a 500 dólares esto
sucede porque la innovación la velocidad
de la innovación tecnológica va muy
rápida tanto va tan rápido que pueden
procesar la misma cantidad de memoria
más poder de procesamiento por el mismo
precio o menor precio y esto lo ves
cuando compras una laptop a pantallas de
tv teléfonos etcétera